sur le territoire de la fédération de
russie dans la maire de pexiora se
trouve une île artificielle dont la
superficie est équivalente à deux
terrains de football
la plateforme pétrolière prirazlomnaïa
ne peut accueillir que 200 personnes
prêtes à travailler dans les dures
conditions du grand nord
ici pour la première fois dans
l'histoire est extrait l'arrco ou
article paul le pétrole arctique
[Musique]
la plateforme prirazlomnaïa est une
véritable ville autonome en arctique
ici on travaille jour et nuit
[Musique]
un quart de travail sur prirazlomnaïa
dure 12 heures ce qui implique une bonne
endurance physique et une grande
vigilance
sur une plate forme pétrolière tout
travail est difficile
les conditions sont difficiles en
arctique
et vitali vassiliev spécialiste des
services de forage travail à moi sur
deux comme tous ceux qui travaillent en
roulement sur prirazlomnaïa il dit avoir
déjà fêté le nouvel an deux fois sur la
plateforme mais avec du jus à la place
du champagne
l'alcool est strictement interdite
prirazlomnaïa se développent et le
nombre de puits augmente un nouveau
forage va paraît
dans cette configuration il ne faut pas
se dépêcher le plus important est de
s'assurer de la qualité du travail et de
la sécurité la vitesse de descente est
très limité c'est à dire que cela prend
4 minutes de descendre chaque tuyau à 9
mètres plus bas en profondeur la
descente sera encore plus lente afin de
ne pas endommager le câble tous les
puits le prix rase l'homme naya
pénétrons dans la couche pétrolifères
comme les tentacules d'une énorme
pieuvre leur longueur totale sera de 200
kilomètres tout le pétrole extrait
arrive dans des réservoirs spéciaux qui
se trouve à l'intérieur de la plateforme
c'est ce qu'on appelle la méthode du
mythe de stockage le pétrole se trouve
dans les conteneurs de stockage
il en a douze au total il est hébergé
afin d'éviter la formation d'un mélange
air gaz et de minimiser ainsi les
hypothétiques risque d'explosion
prirazlomnaïa repose sur les fonds
marins à 20 mètres de profondeur ces
fondations consiste en un caisson si
solide qu'il peut résister à un séisme
de magnitude 6
doucement à gauche
à gauche bazot
[Musique]
j'oublie d'accord reçu
j'ai participé à la construction de
prirazlomnaïa dès le début ils ont mis
des déflecteurs ses murs très lourd qui
pèse 280 tonnes ou même 320 chacun j'ai
travaillé sur une grue flottante de 420
tonnes
donc je suis aussi la femme la plus fort
du monde qu'on a pu me le dire
l'opératrice de grues janin boldyreva
est la seule femme d prirazlomnaïa à
être impliqués dans le processus de
production
mes proches me disent que je suis
obsédée par mon travail
oui c'est vrai j'adore mon travail
chaque grue a son propre caractère elles
sont vivantes en quelque sorte
parfois je rêve que je n'arrive pas à
arrêter la plateforme
gérard est obligé de quitter la cabine
de la grue alors que le vent se met
brusquement a soufflé plus fort si les
rafales sont de plus de 17 mètres par
seconde
le travail sur les sites extérieurs est
suspendu c'est trop dangereux pour le
tanker kirill lavrov
le voyage depuis mornant ce jusqu'à prix
rose l'homme bahia dure environ deux
jours
bonjour veuillez noter le rapport météo
direction du vent 229 vitesse du vent
6,8 m par seconde
mais reid et merci impossible de lutter
contre le climat
on ne peut que s'adapter et exploiter
son potentiel on calcule de façon très
précise le créneau horaire durant lequel
la direction du courant permettra de
commencer le travail
un rosbif voilà la fenêtre que l'on a
pour la manoeuvre et c'est là je suppose
que nous devons arrêter pour le
changement
voilà la fenêtre de travail qu'on a
[Musique]
il est impossible de planifier l'horaire
à la minute près dans l'arctique
il faut toujours prendre en compte
plusieurs facteurs l'état de la glace le
vent le courant grave l'homme naya ici
le pétrolier kirill la voit ici en juger
par les observations et les rapports le
courant arrive je vous demande la
permission d'entrer dans la zone des mm
pour nous y arrêter et attendre jusqu'à
ce que les conditions soient favorables
lavrov reçu c'est clair un instant nous
faisons partie de cette plateforme la
plateforme elle-même sans nous n'existe
pas nous sommes un tout lorsqu'on
s'approche d'elle les systèmes doivent
fonctionner de concert
quelques heures avant la tâche
principale
l'équipe de prirazlomnaïa se mobilise
toutes les données sont vérifiées encore
et encore
alors on a un déchargement demain après
le déjeuner il faut prévoir le pétrole
il faut chauffer les réservoirs
on va décharger combien réservoir la cie
réservoir ok on décharge six réservoirs
en même temps ça fait environ 9000 alors
et on en aura combien avant le déjeuner
environ 20 milles la russie est le
premier pays à avoir une plateforme sous
ces latitudes
d'autres états ont fait des tentatives
mais ont tous échoué prirazlomnaïa est
installée au delà du cercle polaire sur
le plateau continental russe à 55
kilomètres du village de warrants day
la course à l'appropriation et
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
du grand nord dure depuis longtemps
seuls les meilleurs des meilleurs
peuvent l'emporter chaque des
chargements de pétrole est l'occasion de
vérifier l'aptitude professionnelle des
équipes mon jeu et on a déjà fait 27
déchargement et jusqu'à présent pas une
goutte de pétrole ne s'est retrouvé dans
la merde à jean monnet on parle là de
l'équivalent de 10 millions de barils
on peut donc extraire et décharger le
pétrole en toute sécurité
alerte à l'attention du personnel de la
plateforme passer en mode sécurité et
rejoignent immédiatement les points de
rassemblement
sur la plateforme il y a deux équipes de
secours qui peuvent intervenir si des
accidents surviennent ces personnes ont
reçu une formation spéciale
[Musique]
la première équipe de secours composée
de sept personnes est prête pour sa
mission est donc 8 à 10 minutes pour se
préparer
chaque employé à une carte individuelle
portant prénom et nom de famille il faut
l'insérer de manière à ce que le côté
rouge soient orientés vers l'extérieur
cela signifie que cette personne est en
sécurité si quelqu'un n'a pas eu le
temps de le faire
il faut aller la chercher dans la zone
des 8 dans la salle des machines du
maintien de la pression
deux détecteurs de fumée déclenché on y
va suivez moi une carte n'est pas en
place les secouristes doivent retrouver
la personne qui ne s'est pas présenté au
point de rassemblement il ya une chance
de la sauver
[Musique]
après oui
sergei prend le avec les demain
vas-y avance c'était un exercice de tel
entraînement on obligatoirement lieu une
fois par semaine les scénarios des
situations d'urgence sont écrits à
l'avance pour l'année à venir
c'est la victime et sur le brancard
enfin d'alert on analyse chaque détail
on en fait toute une affaire
toute opération qui se déroule sur
prirazlomnoïe ya est examinée sous
différentes afin d'identifier les
risques possibles afin de déterminer ce
qui est nécessaire pour que tout se
déroule en toute sécurité istres le
pétrole est déchargée de prirazlomnaïa
dans deux pétroliers de classe brise
glace ils peuvent fonctionner toute
l'année
l'un d'eux est en cours de déchargement
un gourmand ce qu est celui ci le
pétrolier qui rit lavrov
sa prof de la plateforme 17h05
nous nous sommes arrêtés à la frontière
de la zone des 500 m ont fait une
vérification on vous fera savoir quand
on sera prêt on revient défi tout elle
ne cherche jamais à maîtriser
l'environnement
on tente de le suivre sous ces latitudes
des surprises peuvent surgir de nulle
part il semble que la mère ait déjà été
complètement libérée de la glace mais
lorsque le navire s'approche un nouvel
obstacle se dresse
voici des informations pour vous un
honneur de la plate forme il ya des
blocs de glace un grand chambre ok nous
étudions maintenant il faut calculer si
le pétrolier peut s'approcher du point
de déchargement en évitant un amarrage
extrême
ça casse un peu oui ça ne se fissure pas
mais ça s'est mis un peu ça se casse en
morceaux compris on va décider quoi
faire de la marche on va commencer le
d'avis regarde ce qu'on appelle une
distance d'observation l'amarrage
commence par le lancement d'une fusée
depuis la plateforme
nous avons défini la distance de
prirazlomnaïa on va maintenant
qu'appeler les aussières puis les
réduire la fusée sert également de
l'ensaama pour envoyer en premier le
bout le plus fin vers le navire c'est le
premier lien entre le navire et la
plateforme
ensuite des bouts de diamètre plus
importants ils sont fixés et allait
enfin une shah déposé pour maintenir le
navire en position la position
maintenant sécurisée un ensemble
d'installations pour le déchargement du
pétrole est mise en place à l'énorme kyo
ressemblant à une trompe est fixé au
récepteur du pétrolier le récepteur est
également muni des crochets qui doivent
verrouiller la fixation par ce trio le
pétrole arctique est pompée à partir de
prirazlomnaïa il est essentiel est
d'assurer l'étanchéité de la soupape
avant le début du chargement
c'est dangereux la tension est maximale
aux étapes d' approche de fixation du
tuyau et d'amarrage et surtout à celle
du chargement
car le navire est très proche de la
plateforme à 80 mètres environ
le navire mesureront 257 m on peut dire
que la plateforme est à portée de main
sur la plateforme ebs yenni molotov un
marin de l'île artificielle est
personnellement responsable de
l'amarrage et du chargement du pétrolier
on centrale ici contrôleur central
vannes en position commence la
vérification de la ligne verte je vous
demande la permission
vous avez l'autorisation pour commencer
la vérification de la ligne verte reçu
la ligne verte est un ensemble de
conditions obligatoires
il en a trente au total si au moins l'un
de ces critères n'est pas respectée les
vannes se ferment le déchargement
s'arrête et cela se produit en l'espace
de six secondes
lavrov ici central radio le poste de
contrôle a annoncé la première tonte le
déchargement a commencé se demandent
confirmation quand on aura atteint le
millier jeu confiant la réception des
cargaisons reçues pour information nous
travaillons avec six ponts que ça veut
dire qu'on assimile le déchargement est
un marathon qui dure plusieurs heures et
qui peut s'interroger tout moment selon
les prévisions les conditions
météorologiques dans la région de free
rase l'homme naya vont à nouveau changer
ce qui signifie on ne réussira pas à
remplir les réservoirs du pétrolier d'un
seul coup il s'agit là de 70 mille
tonnes le caire- hilarante devra
s'éloigner et samarie à nouveau
surpris raso mena ya tous les
départements travaillent 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 y compris le
laboratoire où l'on surveille la qualité
du pétrole
le laboratoire et les yeux du complexe
technologique
nous évaluons différents paramètres que
les ingénieurs prennent en compte pour
donner leurs recommandations concernant
le traitement du pétrole
la moindre erreur de chiffres pour un
mètre cubes de pétrole chargé peut
entraîner de graves pertes
on va maintenant mesurer la densité du
pétrole à l'aide d'un densimètre
automatique
[Musique]
qui à biot mounir qui 14 ses volumes de
pétrole qui sont déchargées qui sont
finalement recalculé à partir de sa
densité
il ya une corrélation directe entre la
quantité livrée et le coût de la
cargaison est ce le pétrole et de haute
qualité
ces caractéristiques répondent aux
normes internationales le pétrole
extrait prirazlomnaïa et d'un nouveau
type à faible teneur en paraffine est
indispensable pour la production de
toutes sortes d'huiles son point de
congélation et de moins 48 degrés ce
type de pétrole a été mis sur le marché
en 2014 sous le nom darko où petro
l'arctique
lavrov la preuve ici contrôleurs les
veines sont fermés et pouvons-nous
commencer le changement en azote
je pouvais vous répétez commencé tout
est prêt reçu la touche finale consiste
à nettoyer tous les systèmes après le
chargement les vannes sur le pétrolier
et sur la plateforme doivent être
remises en parfait état
la pression est équilibré dans tout le
système pouvait terminer de débrancher
le tuyau et fermer la vanne commence à
débrancher
voilà à noter l'heure du débranchement
[Musique]
quelle est la roche
les branchements terminé 22 fermes et
reçu attendons m kelly a une bonne
raison de voir son service se terminer
sans problème à la maison sa femme et sa
fille l'attendent clip en selle si les
bacs sont interdits nous ne pouvons pas
les porter pour des raisons de sécurité
il veut très pose comment elle réagit
elle estime que c'est normal
comment devrait-elle réagir le travail
c'est le travail que toujours mieux que
d'aller en mer pour quatre cinq six ou
neuf mois
voilà qui n'est pas bon non plus et ici
on travaille à moins sur deux sites est
stable bien sûr que je vais rentrer à la
maison
il faut laisser les autres travaillaient
aussi on ne peut pas tout faire
et voilà en une seule session nous avons
donc chargé environ 20 mille tonnes
c'est un très bon résultat pour la
première tentative
nous allons bientôt achevés le
chargement après quoi on se dirigera
vers mourmansk
[Musique]
mon père était en mer puis il a trouvé
un travail sur le continent mon grand
père était aussi marin il va accéder au
grade de capitaine et pris une retraite
bien méritée je représente donc la
troisième génération des marins si tous
les chiffres concordent sur le papier
lorsqu'elles viennent y prépare son
rapport final sur le démarrage du
pétrolier depuis la plateforme
ils peuvent faire ses valises
l'opératrice de grues jada boldyreva ans
retournera sur le continent avec lui
bien sûr qu'elle est professionnel au
monde maintenant elle est la seule femme
a travaillé sur le plateau continental
de la fédération de russie en article 6
les choses voir intégrer les vraiment
super puis elle s'occupe des cargaisons
et le trafic de fret est énorme ici
aucun traitement de faveur net appliqué
à jana parce qu'elle est une femme
cela concerne le travail comme
l'équipement
surprise l'homme d'aia le code
vestimentaire est stricte
oui de toute la journée je porte un
bonnet ou un casse-croûte copains alors
mis coiffure ne tient pas c'est pourquoi
il faut se servir du maquillage halte à
l'eau ici que des chaussures fermées à
talons bas vous ne pouvez pas grimper à
une échelle avec des talons ou des tongs
je porte des chemises des tee shirts et
tous qui rien de spécial tout le monde
ne réussit pas toujours à concilier
travail et vie personnelle
ce sont deux mondes parallèles à chaque
fois j'apprends avec elle d'une
photographie de son mari voilà cette
photo a été prise quand il avait 50 ans
la cause qualité son nom âneries
[Musique]
home sûreté qu'il avait des problèmes de
coeur il est mort ce monsieur une fois
je les sauver c'était sa deuxième
attaque cardiaque
j'ai pratiqué le massage cardiaque mais
ce jour-là il est mort peu après mon
retour de la plateforme partir jallet a
travaillé toute sa vie dans des équipes
masculines elle s'y habituer
elle connaît le caractère de chacun
d'entre eux et c'est ce qu'il faut pour
établir le contact
ici elle se sent en sécurité voilà qui
est devenu après douze heures de dur
travail une tradition pour vitali
vassiliev
il vient travailler à prirazlomnaïa
depuis déjà deux ans il prépare le
lancement de nouveaux puits c'est ici à
prirazlomnaïa qu'il a appris qu'il était
devenu père pour la troisième fois
c'était en décembre
c'est ma troisième fille on est sur le
départ donc ce n'est pas inhabituel ici
les enfants naissent et grandissent
alors que nous travaillons ici
que faire rien
[Musique]
c'est que faire
rien ici tout le monde est en manque de
son chez soi c'est la même chose pour
tout le monde je crois qu'au même moment
où l'on part on a envie de rentrer
prirazlomnaïa attire des spécialistes de
différentes professions car seules les
technologies des plus modernes sont
utilisés ici
en travaillant sur la plateforme vous
êtes toujours à la pointe de la science
quand des charges rien sur la plateforme
cela signifie que tous les liquides
résiduelles sont transportés sur le
continent'' ou s'il s'agit de déblais
ils sont pompés à travers le trou de
forage dans une couche spéciale
même s'il ya une fuite d'huile technique
tout restera ici rien ne doit s'écouler
le système de protection maximale
mais mieux vaut prévenir que guérir on
donne de nouvelles alertes
cette fois ci dans le village de
warrants des sur le continent à 55
kilomètres de la plate forme avec un
courant comme celui ci le pétrole
déversé en mer atteindra rapidement la
côte bitchage revenez à la position de
départ
ok bien reçu
l'équipement électrique vérifier très
haut déversement du pétrole est bien
reçu commencée le ramassage
[Musique]
on est arrivés sur le site de
déversement de produits pétroliers sur
la côte de l'île de warrants day ou doit
arriver la nappe de pétrole selon le
plan d'entraînement lancé le
motopropulseur soyez prêts à métal ou
les écumeurs de pétrole numéro a reçu 3
seule la pratique permet d'apprendre
on répète encore et encore certains
exercices
c'est un plan d'action en cas d'urgence
afin de devenir capable de le remplir
les yeux fermés
[Musique]
à cet endroit sûr prirazlomnaïa un
nouveau puits sera foré l'équipe dont
fait partie vitali vassiliev spécialiste
des services de forage procèdent aux
derniers préparatifs
le puits n'est de légumes de mer et dans
l'effort
on termine le forage on descend déjà la
pompe à pétrole
quand nous aurons terminé le travail
nous pouvons entrer à la maison
les membres de l'équipe qui ont fini
leur service sur la plateforme n'ont que
dix minutes pour faire leurs valises
ils doivent transmettre le quart en
personne
et bien développe sauf de les derniers
détails quelques secondes avant son vol
toutes les formalités concernant le
chargement du pétrole sur le navire sont
réglés à ce moment là
l'opératrice de grue jeanne a beau ne
dirais pas craignait que le départ de
soit retardé en raison des conditions
météorologiques
mais tout se passe bien aujourd'hui il
n'y a ni pluie ni vent
ce jour là l'équipe de la plateforme a
été à moitié remplacer un mois plus tard
cette équipe reviendra sur prirazlomnaïa
d'où le premier pétrole arctique de
l'histoire est extrait
[Musique]